my story begins
with my mom's sister and i being
evacuated by u.s marines from war-torn
lebanon
to cyprus i remember finding a cotton
candy machine
on the battleship we were on and just
for a fleeting moment
i could enjoy being a kid not a kid
terrified of what he's just experienced
not a kid terrified of what lies ahead
after five long days we finally arrived
in the seattle airport
and a strong smell of coffee welcomed us
to our new home
and our new way of life now this might
seem like a triumphant moment
that now we're saved but it's not always
that simple
as we made our way home i remember a mix
of emotion
we were joyful and relieved but at the
same time nervous
are we going to be okay here
with sudden change comes sudden maturity
and even at a
young age of 11 years old i realized i
had opportunities here in the united
states i didn't have
back in lebanon i was absolutely
fascinated by
the brain and mathematics and i dreamt
that one day
i want to go to college and i want to
become a neuroscientist
just like my hero oliver sacks
as we settled into life in seattle
everything seemed bright
but then one day our foundation
came crashing down my dad had his second
heart attack
but this time it was different this time
he lost his job medical bills piled up
we actually had to relocate from our
home to government housing to afford
rent
i felt as if the ground beneath us began
to crumble
and i started asking myself am i going
to be okay
will i still be able to attend college
one day
i'm still going to become a
neuroscientist right
as the years passed by my dream of
attending college
became more like a figment of my
imagination
i started noticing a growing gap between
myself and my friends
while they during their summers went to
summer camps for robotics coding science
and sports
i stayed home while they received new
computers and video game consoles
for their birthdays i did not
while they started touring college
campuses with their families and getting
private tutors to help them with
sats and personal statements my family
could barely afford a car to get around
with
at this time i was nearing the end of my
high school years
so i had to face my reality and make a
decision
is college still a possibility for me or
should i
pursue something more practical and get
a job and support my family financially
and i had discussions with my family
about college and it was
full of uncertainty questions like even
if i get into college who's going to pay
for it
what are these scholarships and are they
a scam
why neuroscience maybe i could pick
something easier
what if this whole college thing this
whole
university this whole academia science
thing is just not made for families
like us a pivotal moment came
when one of our family friends laura who
had known me since i was uh two years
old
and knew how bad i wanted to go to
college basically forced me to apply
for a high school summer research
internship at the university of
washington
i was so sure that i wouldn't get into
the internship
why pick me out of all the kids but to
my
surprise i got chosen the
the feeling that somebody out there
actually saw potential in me
even though at that time i didn't see
potential in myself
is what inspired me to actually go to
the internship
now on the the end of the first day of
my internship
i thought i had made a huge huge huge
mistake
the kids around me they were so smart so
confident
they already knew how to code it's it's
as if they've trained for this moment
their whole life
i i just didn't belong there i should go
back
on the second day of the internship i
learned i was placed in a lab that dealt
with
a left ventricular assist device which
is a system that you implant for heart
failure patients
and in that moment i really thought
about my dad and his heart problems
and that intrigued me what is this
device and how could i ever contribute
to this device into these people
and that's what pushed me to go in the
third day
on the third day i was given my first
task which is to code up
a small piece of code to simulate the
heat properties of one of
the components that have to go inside
the patient and
we have to make sure that it doesn't
burn the tissue of the patient
i'm terrified i've never coded before
i've never even opened a
program before why did they pick me why
not just another student who should do
it
but at that moment i had to stop and
think
what if i don't take this opportunity
what would my life look like
what if i'm forever constrained by the
financial
circumstances that were handed down to
me
but in that moment i decided to take
control
and it took me two weeks to create this
little piece of code
but in those two weeks i created that
piece of code and little did i know
that this little piece of code would
create the
coil design for the component that
selected out of many in the lab
would end up being used for the first
clinical trials the system underwent
and not only that but it turned out
later on that my coil design was as
close to optimal
as it could be and this is the first
time that i felt the ground
solidify and that the first step i took
in this path
wasn't muddy that it didn't sink me and
i didn't make a fool of myself
that actually this is a path that i can
take and that i want to take
i could go back to my family and say
that i have a contribution and impact to
make in the world and that i can do it
and that college might just be the thing
for me
inspired i uh got into
applied and got into the university of
washington
took part of ever more computational
pieces of work in research at anything
from
seizure predictions to models of visual
cortex
and i'm proud to say that here at mit
i've actually
had the privilege of teaching
programming and how to code to incoming
graduate students in the department and
now as part of the jazieri lab
i studied the computational basis of
counter factual thinking
the same sort of cognitive processes
that went on in that pivotal
moment when i thought what if i take
this opportunity
but what if i don't and today i share my
story
for those of you out there who feel like
me and i want to tell you
that you don't have to be constrained by
the financial circumstances you were
born in
that you can follow the passions of your
heart and the most important thing you
have is not money or connections
but the belief people have in you and
the belief that you have in yourself
and i'm here to say to you that i
believe in you
thank you